nous n'allons pas au siècle de
jeanrichard mais sa femme annick tanguy
nous présente les animaux de la famille
j'allais gauche un citoyen qui voit la
jambe en l'air intelligent
jean richard on peut avoir des seins je
n'ai pas toujours beaucoup de gens vous
savez veulent des singes mais ils
achètent des singes un peu comme on
achète une garniture de cheminée ils se
disent entre la pendule et la petite
japonaise ça fera très bien d'avoir un
singe qui pense pas du tout à l'espace
vital qu'il faut un singe et oh et puis
alors la plupart des singes montrent
même si même dangereux parce que c'est
assez malsain
celui là il a une spécialité c'est que
c'est le seul singes qui ne mord pas
pour une raison très simple ce qui ne se
fait pas non alors il faudrait lui
apprendre se perdre et déjà huit ans
dans des camps ça s'appelle le mag
autriche plus communément le lait ne du
brésil un singe qui prêtent à gré a beau
toucher cas là la fourrure très très
douce bien sûr je les ramenait de guyane
où j'avais joué en tournée et quatre
pièces sur jardin avec un air non si
là-bas le jeu des acheteurs allèles du
brésil et or il s'en vient avec le gros
chien que j'ai dit que je jouais à dire
que le chien sent bien que c'est un
petit il le sent comme un bébé
au fond je crois pas qu'un chien soit
dangereux avec un bébé dès l'instant
qu'ils vie que cette petite chose mais
qui vit à certains un danois harlequins
j'ai eu le grand père super comment il
s'appelle le chien s'appelle l'ip l'ip
qu'est ce que c'est la différence de
danois ont appelé d'anouar le cas les
noir et blanc comme ça il a quel âge
pour il est tout jeune il a l'air plus
d'un an
il ya 14 mois quand vous l'avez eue il
était comment aux tout petits
ça grandit aussi vite avec viva
l'algérie sûrement il nous a donné pas
mal de soucis du côté de des hanches
mais de positif des problèmes os ou des
petits problèmes osseux mais je crois
que tous les danois des hauts et les bas
du classement et les petits douars les
petits mois 60 du caniche maison en fait
jean richard des animaux vous en avez
toujours eu toujours
j'ai toujours été élevé dans un milieu
animalier parce que mon père était
éleveur de chevaux
et c'est d'ailleurs la seule relation
que j'ai avec le cirque
la seule vraie relation j'en ai eu
d'autres mais carrément a pas alors par
exemple je peux visiter une chose c'est
que mon père est né dans une ferme
toto il ferme qui s'appelait la
ménagerie ce qui est très rare pour une
ferme louis et le premier théâtre que
j'ai dirigé à paris s'appelle théâtre du
chapiteau qui n'avait rien à voir avec
un cirque croyez moi tels sont les seuls
rapports mais finalement tout en nous
toute votre vie tourne autour des
animaux à l'homme socialo et un mur
entourant et jean la maison il ya
toujours eu des nattes ou cela il
s'appelle comment les petits noirs ça
sert à boeing à bouillir à boeing
et puis il ya un autre lot s'appelle dit
tout le mal mais vous avez aussi une
super g à léopard parce que panthère et
les opa c'est la même chose que les gens
savent très peu
la seule chose qui a maintenant c'est
qu'on appelle panthères les femelles
léopards les mâles que simplement
et alors vous allez voir un léopard qui
a une dizaine d'années qui new delhi
qu'il y en a partout jeune et qui a
gardé son caractère de début parce qu'au
fond les gens vous disent les fauves
open the dark athena
ce qui ne veut rien dire du tout une
question caractère sauver ce caractère
que vous allez me voir elle l'avait dit
tu l'as toujours et elle avait
l'habitude dans la maison avec avec vos
enfants et tout le temps c'est un moment
où elle obtint à
la place févr j'aime bien ça tient bien
tard elle me convient
sept kilos sans terre si l'on considère
liée aux gens avant dix ans à condition
qu'ils soient des très très bonne vue et
500 km c'est peut-être une bonne
centaine sur 1000 cela j'ai travaillé
avec kalia lâché pékin le congrès
l'année j'ai fait un numéro grâce à
l'union avec elle quand les gens
viennent pas aux doigts pour passer une
radio
disons c'est un petit peu le coin des
animaux familiers
on appelait ça dans le temps la firme
aurait
je crois toujours pas la seule ce sont
des animaux qui n'ont pas dresser ils
sont apprivoisés peut-être sûrement
s'est adressé justement j'ai besoin
qu'il se met à table avec vous s'il
fallait qu'est ce que tu veux quoi baby
foot vient pas du pouce vient retouches
kaboul ap un diamant brut ya des maisons
début de soirée puis combien de plus de
deux heures les enfants sont battus
maintenant je crois qu'il est important
de mettre les enfants très jeunes en
contact avec les animaux les animaux qui
peuvent qui peuvent sentir très jeune je
crois que l'important c'est toujours pas
vu les chars les chats c'est toujours un
problème quand on a des chiens toujours
pareil moi les deux petits caniches que
vous connaissez vous avez vu il suffit
de lire le nom de la chappe marquise on
voir la camif nous a plu et passe son
temps à courir après l'achat
sentant comme chiens et chats
il ya des animaux parce que c'est comme
ça tout simplement et que c'est là c'est
la devise de la maison il ya toujours eu
des bêtes
oui c'est un peu eux qui commandent qui
peut se dire que madame n'a pas beaucoup
d'autorité avec eux dites-moi gens si
madame monique tanguy n'avait pas aimé
les animaux qu est ce que vous auriez
fait il aurait fallu telle en épouser un
autre tout simplement